well I can't because I didn't know  anything about it I don't know was it it  will probably be able to find out who  did it they thought they were doing me a  favor because they know I am NOT a fan  of John McCain John McCain Jill's health  care for the Republican Party and he  killed healthcare for the nation I  disagree with John McCain of the way he  handles a vet because I said you've got  to get choice he was never able to get  joy  I got choice I disagreed was young the  game on the Middle East  he helped Ford Bush to make a very bad  decision and go into the Middle East so  I wasn't a fan of John McCain I never  will be  but certainly I couldn't care less  whether or not there's a boat named  after its father